[موسيقى]
ملابسك طعامك اثاثك من اكبر احتياجاتك الى
اصغرها اصبح بامكانك شرائها عبر الانترنت
اليوم وانت جالس في بيتك دون ان تخطو خطوه
واحده نحو الاسواق كل ذلك بفضل ما اصطلح
على تسميته التجاره الالكترونيه فكيف حدث
ذلك تعود نشاه التجاره الالكترونيه لعام
1979 من قبل رجل الاعمال مايكل الدريتش في
المملكه المتحده حيث كان قادرا على توصيل
تلفزيون محلي معدل بجهاز كمبيوتر عبر خط
هاتف لانشاء نظام اتصال من شركه الى شركه
وقد تم بيع النظام بعد ذلك في المملكه
المتحده وايرلندا واسبانيا
بحلول عام
1982 كان يمكن لاكثر من نصف سكان فرنسا
البيع والشراء على مدار 24 ساعه باستخدام
خدمه مينيتال للانترنت الاولى التي كانت
رائجه قبل ابتكار الشبكه العنكبوتيه ورد
وايلد اما اول تجربه للافراد في البيع عبر
الشبكه العنكبوتيه فتمثلت في مجاري بوكس
تاكس لبيع الكتب الذي انشاه تشارلز ام
ستاك في عام
1992 بعدها بثلاثه اعوام كانت امازون
تزدهر كموقع للتجاره الالكترونيه في
الولايات المتحده حيث بدات في بيع الكتب
عبر الانترنت قبل ان توسع مجالاتها على مر
السنين وتشمل الملابس والاث والطعام حتى
الموسيقى والفيديو والالكترونيات والالعاب
خلال الفتره ذاتها اطلق رجل الاعمال
الامريكي بيير اوميديار ايباي كشركه
عالميه للمزادات والتجاره عبر الانترنت
وكانت تقدم خدماتها للبائعين الافراد
والشركات الصغيره في جميع انحاء العالم في
عام
1998 ظهرت نتفليكس كمتجر الكتروني لتاجير
اقراص دي في دي بالبريد وقامت بتغيير
قواعد اللعبه في سوق تاجير الفيديو قبل ان
تتطور لشكلها الحالي
ظهرت فيما بعد ملايين المتاجر الالكترونيه
حول العالم التي اخترقت بدورها اجهزه
الهواتف الذكيه وباتت المتاجر الالكترونيه
جزءا من تطبيقات الهاتف المحمول ما جعل
السوق تاتي في بيتك او ربما محموله في
جيبك ان صح التعبير
[موسيقى]